it's okay girl there is no reason to be
nervous
[Music]
hey dr. Mike oh I know I serve you
coffee across the street sometimes I'm
Tara Karen right yeah Tara who serves me
coffee
that's a I enjoy it every time how are
you gonna see me - um Wow look - this
little lady she's been on the street a
long time don't I relate to being on the
street it was a joke I was just oh
you're not a joking no you're not
prostitute okay so she still has her
anterior fontanelle that's a soft spot
like babies have basically she has a
little hole in her head no no but don't
worry dr. Mike's got the cure I'm gonna
take her in the back for some x-rays on
her noggin you stay here yeah great
you
[Music]
this is me and Brandi's spot and that
right girl
Wow so many kids out here all my friends
are having kids right now my own family
asked me all the time with the hold of
this yeah what is the hold up
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
me wrong with you nothing nothing is
wrong with me
just havin cheating ex-boyfriend sorry
thank you but seriously what's wrong
with you already playing ball you know
how it is so I think I'll give another
track
it's hard to compete with a lady like
brandy this is still just a dog day
right
yes still just a dog date
folks we are certainly in the dog days
of summer it's gonna be keep the change
this is one dollar you look good we're
just super fat I called you for pizza
not a baby just my kids don't like old
people he's lethargic appetite is down
Sam needs to get out there and meet some
new dogs that'll be $300 shoes change
your sister to move away from the door
there's a ridge of action throw you
until I get back from the hospital my
building has a strict no-dog policy so
how am I gonna get you up there
but it's been possible to like volunteer
yes during us today isn't former la Ram
the co-hosting a morning new show the
audience tops you two together try every
spot you've snip on this wall is the
same just wanna help you find your dog
you can't be my best friend this dog has
made us a family
almost don't recognize without steam
coming out to you
landlord just salt the building out from
under us
we got the new tricks charity events
we'll come on down
[Music]
dogs open their hearts to us to love and
to be loved and I find that beautiful
[Music]
oh that's just my equipment whatever
[Music]
you